[Musique]
quand vous étiez enfant ne vous est il
jamais arrivé de prendre l'annuaire de
chercher des noms insolites ridicule
rien que pour vous amuser ou faire des
blagues au téléphone cauchon cucuron un
juron concurrence est dure à porter
importé oui c'est un peu difficile dû
renoncer moins dure peut-être un mot un
peu fort mais disons que ça de sa
demande au moins un effort l'habite
c'est un nom difficile à porter on le
nom de la ville oui c'est pas très
facile à porter enfin
on supporte très facilement ce nom quand
on est adulte c'est beaucoup de c'était
beaucoup plus difficile si vous voulez
quand j'étais beaucoup plus jeune
j'étais enfant scolaire etc
c'est beaucoup plus difficile je suis
arrivé à l'armée la chambre et où on est
tous passés par là je leur ai donné un
laps de temps c'est à dire huit jours je
leur ai dit pendant les jours bon ben
voila je m'appelle la [ __ ] vous amusez
vous faites tout ce que vous voulez mais
dans huit jours ça sera terminé pour les
entoure votre souris après ça sera fini
et puis au bout de neuvième jour je
crois est un petit malin qui a trouvé
drôle de continuer les plaisanteries
alors il a été faire un petit stage à
l'infirmerie
est ce qu'il vous a dit son nom d' non
non pas du tout non nous je savais par
l'intermédiaire de mes patrons qui
l'avait qu'elle était fleuriste comme
lui savait que j'étais fleuriste ou
sommes rencontrés et la première fois
qui m'a écrit il a signé sa lettre
uniquement avec ses initiales
c'était sur les boulevards extérieurs et
j'avais dû passer un feu rouge un peu
mur et il y avait naturellement un agent
de la force publique qui étaient là qui
m'a naturellement arrêté je suis arrêté
il m'a demandé mes papiers je donne et
permis de conduire carte grise etc
il a étudié les papiers quand il a vu le
nom
il a souri largement il m'a dit bon
allez ça va forcer pour cette foule on
voyait que des fois ça donne des
avantages
monsieur meurent de soif est ce que
c'est vraiment difficile à porter votre
nom non maire de sausset pas plus
difficile à apporter qu'autre chose
pourquoi aucune raison quelles sont les
réactions des gens en général les
réactions sont sympathiques avant d'être
charcutière j'étais professeur d'anglais
lu quelques problèmes j'ai hésité à
inscrire mon nom au tableau à la rentrée
je ne faisais pas pelé meurdesoif parler
directeur enfin sa course quelques
problèmes vis-à-vis des élèves inscrire
sur un tableau qu'on s'appelle meurent
de soif en début d'année c'est pas
évident
enfin autrement ça a été la cloche
lacourte
la cuisse alors quand j'étais petit jeu
on a passé un test pour se sélectionner
pour les championnats d'académie parce
que je faisais beaucoup de sport
il y avait une quarantaine de petites
filles à peu près et on nous appelait
dans les starting blocks et 1,60 m
j'avais 10 12 ans à peu près
et monsieur ali la cuisse les quarante
petites filles se sont mis à rire j'ai
gagné la course g il y avait une fille
qui devait me battre parce qu'elles
couraient beaucoup plus vite que moi je
les écraser j'étais dans une rage folle
j'étais élections vous êtes mariés oui
je suis mariée depuis un an avec un
monsieur qui s'appelle chabot et j'ai
gardé mon âme jeune fille donc je
m'appelle madame la cuisse et dans ce
cas d'un petit peu étonnant c'est que le
père de mon mari au départ quand on
n'était pas encore marié a pris au
moment où il sortait avec quelqu'un qui
s'appelait la cuisse et mon mari est
devenu monsieur la crise caucus est dur
à porter pas vraiment pas vraiment
quand votre femme a connu votre nom
est-ce qu'elle a été surprise au premier
abord oui premier rapport est ensuite la
pâte est tellement touchée
pourquoi vous enfants ont-ils changé de
nom et bien comme ayant fait des études
supérieures à lille on a les postes de
cadres et
c'est à dire à responsabilité je crois
que pour eux c'était mieux
c'est difficile d'être cadrée de
s'appeler cocu je crois je crois quelle
était votre métier j'étais dans la
gendarmerie
maréchal des logis en portant ce nom est
ce que vous avez eu peur un jour d'être
cocu jeu je me rends pas compte enfin je
sais pas mais où peut-être cela
n'empêche pas l'autre quand j'ai connu
le nom de mon mari j'ai pensé de cet
état sur nos un sobriquet n'ai pas pensé
plus loin jour là après énormément un
fichier j'ai hésité longtemps à donner
ma réponse nichons c'est dur à porter
non pas du tout vous avez connu de nom
de votre mari tout de suite non mon mari
m'a avoué qu'il s'appelait niche en
quelques jours seulement avant notre
mariage jour j'étais dans un bureau d pt
et j'arrive au guichet je donne mon
papier
il y avait là une employée très grosse
avec une poitrine énorme posé sur le
comptoir et elle commence à être prise
de deux secousses
et puis tout d'un coup prise d'un fou
rire elle n'a pas pu continuer à
s'occuper de moi elle a dû se tenir à
l'écart et un contrôleur envoyer
quelqu'un pour la remplacer
[Musique]
frankenstein c'est un nom dur à porter
oui plutôt un c'est bon la première idée
pour les gens quand on entend le mot
frankenstein ça fait aussi peu monstre
alors que ce n'est pas le monstre c'est
le nom du docteur qui est le créateur de
du monstre en réalité alors les gens
bomba au départ vous regarde anr surpris
se met un peu à rire bombe à quel type
de black vous faites on bat le téléphone
le téléphone incessamment on téléphone
en pleine nuit on vous appelle à 2 3
heures du matin bon je me précipite
comme une folle pensant qu'il ya quelque
chose d'important et j'entends à lomagne
frankenstein
bon je réponds oui ici dracula aaa puis
on vous raccroche au nez bon ben ça
c'est ces courants on entend ça au moins
je sais pas de trois fois par semaine
vous avez décidé de changer de nom
oui dans quelles circonstances eh bien
nous avons décidé de changer de nom
d'une part parce que
nous avons trois enfants deux filles
pouvaient garder leur nom puisque dans
la plus tard en se mariant le change de
nom mais nous avons un fils tu es tu au
cas où il serait devenu docteur ça
posait des problèmes de s'appeler
docteur frankenstein
donc mon mari avait décidé de franciser
notre nom vous êtes seraient pourtant
vous portez un nom différent
moi je m'appelle le claude connart mon
dieu pour moi ça ne pose pas trop de
problèmes pour les autres peut-être
quelques fois mais pour moi
personnellement je n'y vois aucun
inconvénient ça ne me donne pas de
complexe du tout
françoise j'ai totalement réagit
différemment
pour moi c'était comme un handicap
enfin naître avec un handicap est
totalement bloquée à tous points de vue
je ne pouvais pas m'exprimer normalement
je ne pouvais pas réagir normalement
notamment vis-à-vis tu mets mes petits
camarades déjà l'école
qu'avez vous fait eh bien disons que il
ya une dizaine d'années j'ai pris sur
moi de faire les démarches nécessaires
pour changer de nom j'ai pris le nom de
ma mère
le nom de jeune fille de ma mère est bon
mais depuis je me sens totalement
quelqu'un d'autre
monsieur madame bordel c'est un nom
difficile à porter pour moi très pénible
pourquoi parce que dure depuis mon
enfance enfin j'ai entendu que les
quolibets sur ce nous comment s'est
passé votre scolarité assez mal surtout
à partir de 12 ans parce que j'ai déjà
su à peu près là signifie que la
singularité de mon nom sans en
comprendre bien le sens comment vous
vous défendez soit par l'ironie ou soit
par le silence
et puis des fois ça blesse
est-ce que vous avez envisagé de changer
de nom catégoriquement non mon père m'a
est mort le 1er novembre 1918 à vos
dires dans l'ardenne et je n'ai pas cru
devoir manche ont changé mon nom pour
garder dans ma mémoire
son affection madame on vous fait des
plaisanteries au téléphone oui pas mal
de plaisanterie raconté d'intel sont
deux jours c'est rien et quand c'est là
en pleine nuit que vous dormez bien et
qu'on vous téléphone et vous vous levez
dès que vous entendez au bout du fil
est ce qu'il vous reste des chambres
pour la nuit
combien que c'est la passe et moi je
voudrais une japonaise
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez aux
biens je dis bien souvent non nous
n'avons pas ça nous travaillons c'est
complet toute l'année et c'est ce rendez
vous vous êtes allés au oui oui je suis
allé au bordel comme sommes habitués à
connaître le nom je connaissais même de
bonnes adresses dont je n'avais pas les
moyens de est allé mais enfin le
chabanais et le sphinx
[Musique]